oui les français veulent pouvoir choisir
la régulation des naissances qui permet
de choisir le moment où l'on va voir ses
enfants a fait son entrée en france par
la loi de décembre 1967 elle permettait
l'information et la vente des produits
contraceptifs en france la vente des
produits contraceptifs est maintenant
autorisée en pharmacie celle des pilules
est soumise à un certificat médical pour
les personnes majeures
un certificat médical et une
autorisation d'un des parents pour les
mineurs
ce en application crt a beaucoup de
préjugés qui ont retardé la sortie des
décrets d'application où nous sommes
heurtés pour l'application de cette loi
un état d'esprit conservateur rétrograde
je dirais aussi un manque de
clairvoyance de discernement et
peut-être de générosité on a placé les
femmes les coupes devant l'alternative
accouchement avortement sans leur
expliquer sans leur indiquer qu'il y
avait autre chose
on n'a fait aucune éducation sexuelle
vous même vous avez fait comme moi même
de l'auto informations on a découvert
les vérités de la vie au hasard 10 qui
ont glané sous le préau des écoles ou ou
dans les bureaux tout c'est pas sérieux
à ce que vous pensez que des décrets
d'application vont enfin permettre cette
information je viens de voir le premier
ministre et j'ai rencontré en lui un
homme ouvert à ces problèmes et je crois
pas être trop optimiste en estimant que
très prochainement la loi l'arrêté qui
permet enfin l'agrément des centres
d'information et de consultation sera
signait donc ces centres sont à gré et
puis c'est surtout que les moyens d'une
information très large considérable dont
on a besoin vont pouvoir être mises en
place à travers avec l'aide des
associations quelles que soient leurs
tendances confessionnelle ou lake un
problème difficile parce que
l'avortement ne remplacera jamais la
contraception